this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
armouries museum in the uk which houses
a collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and in
this episode we've really broken poor
jonathan by showing him the mad arsenal
of borderlands 3. yeah this this one's
this is not even a gun goodness sake
people be upset if i didn't show you
this
i'm upset that you have shown me this we
showed jonathan a fair chunk of
borderlands 3 so we'll be revisiting the
game for a second episode coming soon so
make sure to subscribe if you want to
check that out later on and if there are
any other games guns or mechanics that
you guys want to see jonathan break down
let us know in the comment section below
right let's dive into the mad guns of
borderlands 3.
yeah
this is my reaction to that
hey the series is called uh
expert reacts and that's my reaction
so as i try to marshal my thoughts here
uh what is this this is a sort of hybrid
pistol carbine thing
but it doesn't have a stock or an
ability to fit one looks to be single
action sort of high-tech lines to it a
permanently attached
bayonet
which is
weird in itself i think i'm probably
looking at the artifact here of putting
a muzzle device on something but if not
you haven't got much bayonet left on
this so in this configuration we've got
what a couple of inches sticking out the
front of blade otherwise you'd have to
use it to sort of slash with which i
suppose would be better than nothing
massive muzzle break on there don't
really know why it looks to be firing
4440 or something similar to that they
don't look like real rounds so it's got
a winchester or a shotgun style side
saddle cartridge holder on the left side
of it a really weird red dot sight with
sort of old school leather eye cup on it
don't know how that's supposed to work
maybe it's just a red dot and that's
just a glare shield let's go with that
and the whole thing looks to break open
for reloading but let's uh let's see how
it works
all right that's a slightly weird take
on fanning which i think we've spoken
about before but is where you hold down
the trigger and you slap the hell out of
the hammer because otherwise you'd have
to [ __ ] it to fire it i don't know what
i think that was some there's either a
special ability let's go with special
ability it almost looked like the
ammunition changed and then he could
suddenly
fan it really quickly so even though
it's manual this is a manually operated
firearm not semi-automatic it's not
fully automatic but we're able to speed
up our manual operation to submachine
gun speeds right so i thought that site
was some sort of a red dot reflex sight
it's not what it is is inexplicably a
lens
rear
aperture
thing and then a weird kind of almost
like light bulb filament front sight out
front essentially this is just an
illuminated front sight like you see on
a pistol with old-fashioned night sights
and then the rear aperture is our really
wide pair of scope bar
reticle things this doesn't make any
sense as a site i'm guessing this just
increases your accuracy when you have it
equipped and it doesn't affect really
how you experience aiming with this
setup that would be my guess
okay we've got some kind of a
submachine gunny looking
space gun thing reminds me of something
and i think that something is a nerf gun
clearly it's beyond my ken as to how
this works so let's just watch it
finally
okay pause there that's a new one so
we we throw this rifle roughly to the
floor and it grows legs
and starts attacking of its own accord
that is very borderlands isn't it
interesting so you've got your own
sentry gun and then
we magically have another one after
we've thrown that one i think i'm going
to struggle to
follow this to be honest with you
of course it has a voice and
it says pew pew it's just it all makes
sense but only within the universe of
borderlands i think
okay they really love trigger guards in
this game otherwise it's another another
gun very far removed from reality maybe
a hint of g36 there with that pseudo
carry handle on the top there and a drum
magazine inspired by some i guess
something like the x products
drum mag and it's a
bullpup so i i automatically have an
affinity for it having written 630 odd
pages on on bullpups oh uh and
yeah this is this is worth mentioning so
it was a very futuristic looking weapon
with some quite recognizable accessories
we've got a an eo techie looking reflex
sight fairly conventional looking
magnifier behind that and a
peq esque laser light aiming module it's
funny how in sci-fi sci-fi games well
actually in movies as well how even if
the gun is quite science fiction the
accessories tend to just be certainly in
some movies off-the-shelf accessories
just just bolted on and this is the sort
of computer game version of that i
suppose it's a sort of visual language
thing that if you're coming over from
something like call of duty you have to
know what these things are intuitively
oh yeah i need a naming module i need a
site i need a
the butt stock even on this is really
quite conventional compared to the rest
of the gun so i think it's probably to
do with accessorization and recognition
factor of those accessories
and also of course because we don't know
what future accessories will will be
will they be fully integrated into the
gun somehow will there be modules that
you click in and out of a housing will
they will they even attach to something
like a picatinny rail who knows
right i'm i'm struggling to think this
this reminds me of something and i think
it's a sort of weird mashup of an svd
and something like the origin 12 shotgun
some source a saigon shotgun with a with
a drum mag on it and then the front half
is just completely wacky don't know what
that is there is several degrees removed
a real gun under all this i think at
least in concept
this is an unusual take on the under
barrel secondary weapon concept
typically a grenade launcher sometimes a
shotgun this is a shotgun too rather
than just firing it from where it is
under the barrel we hit a button and the
whole front of the gun rotates to place
the secondary weapon in front of the
action so
in concepts i suppose that's fair enough
so your your
carrier group operates the feed
mechanism all of that is is
one part and then you change the barrel
for a different type of weapon but then
that would have to have its own feed
device or be single shot anyway i'm not
really seeing what the advantage is here
or you're doubling up on the only one
breach mechanism but the breach
mechanism for an under-barrel shotgun or
grenade launcher is typically a very
simple double-action trigger so not very
bulky or weighty anyway so there would
be no point in this sort of turnover
system we do see that however on muzzle
loaders
and we call them turnover guns because
they don't have a feed mechanism because
the powder and bullet is loaded into the
two barrels and then you rotate you fire
one and then you have a common lock
mechanism which you still have to
re-prime and then you turn over the
barrel cluster
to the other barrel but that's for a
very different purpose than this but who
knows maybe that was the inspiration
seems unlikely yeah there's this one's
this is not even a gun goodness sake
he would be upset if i didn't show you
this
i'm upset that you have shown me this
so iridian fabricator shoots guns
instead of bullets is that one up from
the portal thing where we fire the whole
cartridge why not shoot the gun fires 10
guns per 10 iridium okay so this is some
kind of ammunition or resource in the
game that i'm not privy to and it looks
like that thing from the original series
of star trek that eats
starships
well that was oddly hypnotic to watch so
it is you know does what it says on the
tin it shoots guns uh but not as a
weapon at least i don't think it can be
used as a weapon i'm wondering now if it
can in fact be used like a not very good
weapon like the rock it launcher from uh
fallout don't know maybe we'll find out
and in any case on face value it is what
it says it's a fabricator it produces
lots of guns that you can then choose
from i suppose to actually shoot people
with it's it's funny it's creative what
can i say
wow i don't know if i'm even allowed to
read this out but uh this is apparently
the one pump chump magazine size
of one so even though so it's a pump
action presumably shotgun and even
though it has a
magazine tube below the barrel
apparently that only has one round in it
so i mean what else can i say
right i think i understand this a bit
better now so the combination of the
basic base characteristic of the gun and
the modifier effectively is that you may
get two shots out of it but you might
only get one you don't know and that's
the that's the inherent drawback of the
thing but it does seem to have a decent
amount of damage and i suppose if i'm
really reaching depending where you are
in the world magazine capacities are
restricted can't think of any that are
restricted to a capacity of
one and apart from anything else even
even if you did have a magazine
restricted to one round you could still
put another one in the chamber which
would give you two by default although
it's quite a conventional looking gun it
isn't really
matching up with reality very well
despite basically being a pump action
shotgun of course the glaring issue with
that is that you'd still have to pump it
for the second shuttle the third shot or
the fourth row i mean because this is a
dice roll you could it's essentially a
semi-automatic shotgun that jams after
one or more shots that is styled as a
pump action because even with a
semi-automatic shotgun you have to [ __ ]
it for the first round and that's really
all that you're doing here kind of
intriguing but stupid
interesting looking gun triple barrels i
guess the barrels rotate it's got a
scope if i if i had to categorize this
i'd say it's probably going to be some
sort of light machine gun
but
um the the butt stock and scope suggest
maybe not let's let's try and see get a
handle on how this thing works
so no it's not a machine well no not a
machine gun more of a triple barrelled
anti-materiel rifle and somehow i don't
know why you'd bother yet again we have
a we have a feed mechanism in the back
rotating barrels up front what does
rotating the barrels achieve we couldn't
really achieve anything could it looks
damn cool and sounds good the general
overall appearance of it is yeah it's
like what if we put three barrels like
rotating gatling barrels on an
anti-material rifle and the answer is uh
it'll be pointless
right this game is throwing me for a
loop time after time it is a sort of
hybrid of a gatling machine gun and an
anti-material rifle uh which is i
suppose we can if we think of the the
browning 50 machine gun of the m2 that
was a heavy caliber machine heavy
machine gun large caliber machine gun
that was occasionally used as a stand-in
sniper rifle with a magnifying optic
attached to it because it was inherently
very accurate being a big thick heavy
barrel very long range powerful
cartridge and a
fixed mount so in a pinch you could use
it as an anti-material rifle or a
long-range sniper rifle this is a sort
of fantasy ultimate take on that you
fire it from the hip the barrel spin
round and give you presumably cooling
advantage maybe rate of fire advantage
but then we zoom in and we can fire it
slowly like a sniper rifle
i mean what can i say it's called the
porter pooper 5000 i mean do you really
want
an attempt at serious commentary on this
thing i suppose you're gonna get it i
mean the thing looks like it's covered
in it doesn't it i don't know if there's
a clean version of this gun inexplicably
the yellow bits are clean and then the
rest of it is just brown maybe it's an
aesthetic i don't know all right let's
watch it
well
as we could have predicted
it's a sort of
flamethrower looking grenade launcher
that fires radiated shite
can i say this this is unusual even for
a borderlands game i would suggest and
it just it defies interpretation there's
i'm going to try anyway there's some
sort of a
vented nozzle like a like a well more
like a weed burner really than a
flamethrower but you know reminds me of
video game flamethrower
uh a completely pointless front sight
there
lots of pipes and it's kind of
punting out explosive
radioactive
poo bombs
i tell a lie the front sight is not
completely pointless it is for use in
conjunction with a really terrible rear
sight that has a weird shape for no
reason but at least you've got something
to line up your front sight with i
suppose and then
yeah i'm not entirely sure what's
happening with the rest of it we seem to
be re-coating it with poop
at one point
come on come on the ground snakes poking
through my ass grass
join us again next time and in the
meantime if you'd like to donate to us
there are links in the description
goodbye
[Music]
you